hi everyone i'm ella a customer engineer
at google cloud welcome back to the
technical series for startups where
we're creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably with google
cloud
at this stage we've taken you through
some key storage and analytics services
that will enable you to accelerate your
business with google cloud
in our last video we introduced
processing as a key component of your
data architectures by explaining how you
would manage spark and hadoop clusters
on the google cloud platform
however for digital startups today there
is so much more that you might need to
achieve when it comes to processing and
so in this video we'll introduce you to
dataflow and in particular how you can
facilitate your stream processing
pipelines
in this session we'll answer the
following questions
what could dataflow bring to your
business
how do you start using dataflow
we will take you through a demonstration
that will address how you design scale
and optimize your data flow pipelines
and then we'll look into how other
businesses are implementing this service
so what can dataflow bring to your
business
to set some context classical analytics
typically seeks to answer the question
what has happened when it comes to using
data to make informed business decisions
while this is still relevant in many
ways it often leads to building
dedicated infrastructure that hunts for
data across many business systems and
acts on data that's sometimes old
increasingly we are seeing businesses
change that question to what is
happening
by producing unified systems that
integrate data in real time and produce
live insights that can be acted on now
making this shift isn't easy and
crossing the digital transformation
chasm so to speak requires a bridge
that's built with an end-to-end software
stack to meet these real-time
requirements and design patterns that
will enable this unified system
so how do we go about building this
bridge
well fortunately we've built most of it
for you with our managed service
dataflow
it allows you to build a unified system
for your extract transform and load
processes that captures both real-time
and batch data in a fast scalable and
cost-effective pipeline
the key advantages of dataflow are that
it is fully managed so it removes your
operational overhead when it comes to
scaling optimizing and provisioning your
processing pipeline it is portable
because all pipelines are built with an
open source apache beam library it is a
unified processing pipeline which means
you don't need to recreate the wheel
when it comes to your batch first
streaming processes you can easily use
the same pipeline for both patterns
it offers comprehensive built-in support
which means your pipelines will be fault
tolerant consistent and correct
regardless of their complexity
it also shows throughput and lag
statistics as well as login system
checks which means that regardless of
this complexity your pipelines are
simple and seamless to manage
and lastly it's easily integrated with
other google cloud products which
enables you to access the best of cloud
using native integrations with services
like bigquery or vertex ai or perhaps
cloud storage and other google cloud
services meaning that you can build
rapidly and in a trusted environment
this efficient and reliable streaming
capability enables your business to move
from reactive to proactive processing
in fact one of the world's leading music
streaming services describes how
dataflow is enabling this shift
before dataflow no one really wanted to
write streaming jobs because they were
too difficult or frustrating and no one
really did it at all
but now more than 40 to 50 of all new
jobs when it comes to processing are
streaming
so how do you start using this
technology when it comes to
implementation there are two pathways
that you can take
the first is if you have simple
requirements for your pipeline with
fairly trivial transformations and you
want to get them up and running quickly
and easily the second path you can take
if your etl processing requires you to
make some more complicated
transformations with more intricate
management of pipelines
if path 1 sounds like the right fit then
use our pre-built data flow templates
right from the console or with the
google cloud api
if path 2 is more suited to your
development needs then you can start
building your pipeline with the apache
beam software development kit and run
that on dataflow
to dive further into these options
dataflow templates allows you to create
manage and adapt the most common use
cases within dataflow all without really
writing a line of code
we also have user-defined functions
which allows you to build upon these
pre-built templates to suit your
business needs
alternatively apache beam is an open
source set of sdks that facilitate an
interaction with the overall data
processing model and is the language
through which you specify your data flow
processing pipelines
within the beam sdk
you specify your pipeline as a data
source and a data sync
between these you perform a series of p
transforms which are operations or
functions of sorts that are performed on
objects called p collections
each p collection is immutable and p
transforms can be executed in parallel
here's a short example of what that
might look like for a small series of
transformations that are performed using
a cloud storage source and a bigquery
sync
notice that this is specified in java
but beam also supports python and go
another key concept to familiarize
yourself with when you start using data
flow is windowing for a data stream new
elements are always being produced and
we need some sort of strategy to ensure
all elements are captured and processed
exactly once
if you want to perform live aggregations
on your data pipeline then you need to
divide that data into event time-based
chunks called windows
by default dataflow has a single global
window but this isn't always useful for
real-time aggregation
different types of windowing strategies
that you can use include
fixed windows where data is divided into
discrete time chunks and aggregation
occurs after each time chunk and data
can only belong to one of those windows
there are also sliding windows which are
essentially overlapping fixed windows
which allows aggregation to be performed
more frequently
another common pattern is session
windows where the windows size is
defined by a gap in user activity
such that windows then represent bursts
of individual user activity
this is really common in e-commerce and
gaming use cases and is supported in
dataflow
given these two pathways let's dive into
a simple way that you can get these up
and running with either dataflow
templates or apache beam
we're going to be working with a public
data set called new york city taxi rides
where real-time data is published on
taxi rides across new york city to a
public pub sub topic
let's say we wanted to store all of this
data in our own data warehouse on
bigquery in order to perform some kind
of real-time analytics on it
the architecture for that might look
something like what we've got here
pub sub data flow bigquery
if we want just the live raw data
without too many complex transformations
then that sounds like a great use case
for dataflow templates
you can see here that we've set up a
bigquery data set and table with a
schema that aligns to the json payload
that we expect to receive from the taxi
rides public pub sub topic
you can also see by navigating to
preview that there are no current
observations in the table yet and that
it's completely empty
this means we have our pub sub source
ready to go as well as our bigquery sync
all set up
from here we navigate to the dataflow
console and start by creating a new job
using a template
we'll use the pub sub topic to bigquery
template
we'll also specify things like name
the region to host the dataflow instance
in
the taxi ride's public topic that we
want to listen to
a temporary storage bucket for our data
flow pipeline
and the bigquery table where we want our
data to end up
from here it's as easy as clicking run
job
we can see that our job is now up and
running so let's head back to the
bigquery table to see if we can see data
being ingested
and you can see here that there is
already live data that is streaming into
the table that we've created ready for
analysis
pretty cool right
however what if i don't really want to
be storing all of that raw data that's
coming in from the pub sub topic
let's just say i work in a finance
department of a new york city taxi
company and i want to get a live
aggregate of the meter readings so i can
get an understanding of how much money
is coming in for a given time window
well that sounds like i'd need to do
some more complex transformations and
implement some windowing which isn't
really covered by dataflow templates
necessarily
and in this case we need to use
something like apache beam to specify
our own pipelines
so let's have a look at how you can
launch a beam pipeline on dataflow
remember that the apache beam sdk is
supported in java python and go
today we'll use the python sdk so that
we can take advantage of google's
managed jupyter notebooks which we can
launch straight from the dataflow
console
i'm going to spin up an instance by
navigating to workbench on the dataflow
console
and then specifically user managed
notebooks
and then launch a new notebook which
will give me the option to select an
apache beam specific environment
from here i'll launch my jupiter labs on
this instance
and note that you can of course use your
local environment if you prefer to do
that instead
now that i've launched into this
instance you can see my apache beam
pipeline specified in a notebook file
notice that i've specified the import
for a data flow runner
my pub sub topic that i'd like to read
from
all of the options required for this
streaming pipeline which you can read
more about on the apache beam website
and because we're reading for an
unbounded source i've created a sliding
window at 10 second intervals with one
second for each slide
i've also chosen to pull out the meter
increment variable so that we can
aggregate that variable and send the
results to our bigquery sync
and finally we use the beam io module to
write to our bigquery sync and then
specify to run the pipeline
and then once we run these cells in our
notebook we should see that a dataflow
job has been spun up back on the
dataflow console we can see that this
job has been successfully launched
and when we navigate to bigquery we can
see that this live aggregate data is
being streamed directly into our new
table
so now that you have these pipelines up
and running you can optimize them by
observing and managing their execution
graphs and job metrics
these are tools targeted to help you set
measure and meet your service level
objectives or slos
these capabilities provide you with a
visual way to inspect data as it moves
in and out of your system so that you
can identify the bottlenecks
these tools also provide an automatic
way to identify and tune your
performance and availability problems
and finally when it comes to scaling
your data architectures dataflow has
been built to scale with you
if we pop the hood on this service we
can see that its secret source is in all
of these things that it's doing in the
background
importantly
dataflow chooses the appropriate number
of worker instances required to run your
job and will automatically scale to
fewer or perhaps more workers at run
time based on the specific
characteristics of your pipeline
so then
how are other companies using dataflow
in their data architectures
mses is a great example of how dataflow
can bring real-time capabilities to a
data architecture
mses is one of the world's leading
marketing platform companies enabling
personalized one-to-one interactions
between customers and marketers across
all channels
mses uses pub sub dataflow bigtable and
bigquery to build a scalable digital
marketing platform that integrates
real-time analytics and builds real-time
ai models
by performing real-time event processing
at scale mscs was able to reduce the
cost of their ai platform by 70
as well as significantly improve their
user experience which is pretty cool
right
so if you've gotten to the end of this
video and you still want to hear more
about dataflow here are some steps that
you can take
firstly have a read of the dataflow
documentation as well as some common
dataflow use cases
watch some of our more in-depth
demonstrations of the dataflow service
online
get hands-on with our online courses
and finally reach out and get connected
with someone from google cloud on how
dataflow could work for your business
you'll find a link for all of these
items in the description below
next up in this series we'll be moving
on to data visualizations with data
studio
where we'll cover what the data life
cycle is what data studio is and how it
works
how you can start creating reports with
data studio and how other customers are
using it with their visualization
workloads
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel and click on the
bell to get notified for each time a new
video is posted
thank you for listening and stay tuned
for more on how you can start building
your startup with google cloud
[Music]